[Music]
I'm really happy to be here this morning
and it's the first session right so yeah
you guys are in a good mood right I mean
it's morning it's the first time we're
actually another way to frame this talk
which is around sort of rethinking
happiness and a lot of this work is
actually based on our research on
meaning and purpose and some nascent
work on humor as well and and a lot of
this is done and codified in two classes
I teach with Naomi bad doughnuts called
rethinking purpose and humor serious
business so I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about the research but first
does everyone have a piece of paper can
they take a piece of paper out cuz I'm
gonna ask you a bunch of questions and
give you like 30 seconds to respond to
very kind of thought-provoking questions
all right
here's what I find I find that if I just
talk at you you're gonna think this is
entertaining or interesting but if I
force you to write something down you
all have a piece of paper that you will
take home and maybe show someone and the
behavior change that happens afterwards
is dramatically different all right you
got a piece of paper right all right
this is gonna be pretty fast but if you
have any questions just email me they're
also all of this research is posted on
my website at Stanford so you can go and
download anything tell your grandkids
kids whatever alright so what we're
gonna do in a fairly short period of
time is go over a brief history of the
happiness research
I'll put forth another way of rethinking
our approach to happiness
anchor on that new destination which is
is focused on purpose and then talk
about what to pack for the journey and
then what to do on Monday all right so
the happiness research has long been
well documented
and not only academic papers but a ton
of books there is no shortage of data in
an anecdote about the power of being
happy and certainly a being happy does
correlate with a lot of really positive
things like productivity and creativity
and oftentimes meaningfulness etc
however there's a hitch in all of this
research that's teaching us the power of
being happy we oftentimes overshoot
there's a lot of misperceptions about
happiness and the reality is can we just
can we just take a moment and just say
it is a shitshow out there right now
seriously in the last month just think
about it in the last month we've had
hurricanes we've had earthquakes we've
had mass shootings and the threat of
violence is very real every morning you
wake up and you think it's it's pretty
hard to be happy if if happiness is our
goal how are we going to take on big
challenges in life how do we absorb
what's happening on our world and how do
we actually figure out how we want to
contribute in positive ways so what does
drive happiness if our instincts aren't
always aligned with what makes us happy
this is this is some research that's
pulled together from a line of different
papers and the thing that's really
interesting is that oftentimes the
things that we believe brings us
happening happiness don't as much as we
think so we often think religion will
bring us happy happiness and it does but
not as much as we think now if you go
volunteer and not just go to church
temple synagogue and you actually
volunteer and help others that actually
correlates with happiness more than we
think but just going and showing up
doesn't as much as we think and you've
seen all of this research money over and
above a certain threshold doesn't matter
as much as we think it does matter but
maybe not as much as we think
what does matter are things over here
this right hand side so if you give your
children anything that would be a sense
of self-esteem that wouldn't matter more
than we think dancing and social skills
so that you have thriving relationships
matters more than we think you know free
time isn't you know you got fired so you
have a lot of free time it's the feeling
that you can control your time that
matters more than we think and the
second may be misperception and trap of
happiness has a lot to do with this
hedonic adaptation that once we finally
arrive at that promotion that within
three very short days we're back at our
base levels of happiness so we adjust
surprisingly quickly the good news of
course is that the things that we fear
the most in life oftentimes when they
happen don't hurt as badly or as long as
we think they will so there's both good
and bad news with this um the third
misperception or trap of happiness has a
lot to do with this idea of valuing
happiness maybe too much
there can be paradoxical boomerang
effects which sound fun but they can
also hurt iris moss and her colleagues
do studies where they they tell half of
the subjects you know basically in a
default condition you don't have to do
anything differently and another
condition they'll say you know happiness
is really important you should value
happiness and seek it and then they'll
expose the two conditions to you know
sort of videos that normally would make
you happy puppies playing etc and the
individuals in the happiness condition
are significantly less happy than the
individuals in the control condition and
what seems to be happening is that you
know we have these expectations that
that rise up and if we expect to be
happy and we are valuing happiness so
much that our expectations raise the gap
between expectations in reality or
performance is significant and that
drives down happiness levels by the way
this little model very simple model is
something that I use all of the time
get home I constantly burn things take a
picture myself burning things invite my
kids to see me burning things and then
say well you know I just don't cook and
their expectations of me cooking are at
all-time low low levels so if I ever
cook they are just like giddy giddy with
glee so you can use this tool at home as
well
forth we think happiness is one thing we
think it's relatively stable either have
it or we don't but the meaning of
happiness changes in very systematic
ways over our life course and even
within the day I have researched with
Cassie McGill nur and sepka bar in one
of the data sets we we pull from the we
field find data set that SEP converge at
Jonathan Harris created and separate
algorithm that combs the blog of the
blogosphere for all mentions of I feel
and I am feeling and this single slide
combines 12 million data points global
data points of blogs because blog based
data has demographics associated with it
we can start to understand what people
are talking about when they blog and
what they're feeling
so the way to read this is we start out
simple and these are 11 to 14 year old
bloggers and how many of you have
teenage kids all right so when you say
how are you feeling they say fine what'd
you do today nothing right John's kind
of internalized that so there's not this
big emotional lexicon associated with 11
to 14 year old and they don't really a
moat um but soon they soon they fill up
with eggs so 15 to 18 they start to feel
very anxious when they do feel happy
it's equated to excitement so literally
I feel happy means I feel excited and
then feelings of confinement around 20
they start to feel unknown alone kind of
empty until we leave those feelings
behind to go conquer the world at 25
they start to feel more powerful and the
allure
money power or status starts to
correlate with their happiness before
gradually trading ambition for balance
around 30 they start to talk more about
not feeling balanced or wanting to feel
more balanced developing an appreciation
for our physical body is at 35 they
start to wonder why they feel overweight
or out of shape they forgot to work out
and all of a sudden magically their
bodies have gone downhill and then our
children they're only as happy as their
least happy child and evolving sense of
connectedness after which we feel
grateful happy calm and blessed and some
of you know like we don't die at 50 it's
just that the blog based data you know
shrinks substantially so they just cut
it off I don't want any of us to worry
but the migration path of happiness is
from excitement all the way to
contentment so if a 50 year old says I
feel happy it means I feel content
peaceful grateful now it's not always
linear we can also experimental e
manipulate these things so 50 year olds
can act and behave like 18 year olds and
18 year olds can act and behave like 50
year olds and so if you go into our
research program you can see all of
those studies but to summarize this what
we find is that individuals move from a
mindset of discovery where the promise
of happiness is excitement and then they
move into pursuit where the promise of
happiness is that feeling of conquering
the world and then you move into balance
where the fueling of happiness is about
alignment or the opportunity to have
work and health and family all sort of
be thriving then you move to impact
where the meaning of happiness is more
aligned with feeling meaningful or a
sense of significance much more outward
looking and then you move to savoring
where the meaning of happiness is
equated to as I said contentment or
peacefulness and because people are
making decisions based on optimizing
their happiness and our research is
showing that the meaning of happiness is
shifting and really differ
waise what that means is when you are
optimizing for happiness as excitement
you're making really different decisions
about what beverage to drink what car to
buy who to marry versus if you're
optimizing for contentment or balance so
it has dramatic impact on the choices we
make in our life so what this research
shows is that we often pursue happiness
and yet once we attain it or you know
what it is its meaning changes and we
start the pursuit again so the question
is can we rethink our approach to
happiness so how might we create
products cultivate organizations and
live lives that cultivate happiness if
we can't aim for it now here's where
you're gonna hate me just briefly I'm
gonna contend that it has a lot to do
with destination and journey yes new
research confirms what old wise people
told us forever Ralph Waldo Emerson
wrote life is a journey not a
destination TS eliot writes the journey
not the destination matters Confucius
roads were made for journey not
destinations so first let's talk a
little bit about destination or this
concept of a North Star so destination
in our rethinking purpose class when we
have a whole bunch of students in the
class feels often very daunting or
elusive when we ask individuals what is
your purpose they'll often say I have no
clue in fact I'll just raise of hands
how many of you in this room were just
born with a sense of purpose or this
idea of what you were meant to do raise
your hands okay so usually it's about
this like this is actually less for you
normally it's about 5% and I think there
was like three people and and that's
what we find right like the large
majority people weren't you know gifted
with this internal sense of like I must
be a ballet
you know dancer or whatever so the
question is how do we help this student
Anker on purpose if it's so elusive what
is this thing that's deeply meaningful
to you now a little caveat our research
shows that happiness and meaningfulness
are though correlated around point five
and by the way these constructs which
are both very positive things correlate
around point four when you're younger
all the way to point eight when you're
older and so that they become more
intertwined and you start to understand
that what is deeply meaningful for you
is in fact bringing you happiness but
not when you're younger so how are they
different and one of our papers we asked
individuals you know to what degree do
you have a happy life to what degree do
you have a meaningful life and then
we'll correlate these metrics and
impartial out the positive covariance so
we're just looking at people who say you
know that they have a happy but not that
meaningful life or people that have been
meaningful but not that happy life so by
kind of forcing them apart we can start
to understand how they have these
different mindsets a few of the biggest
differences happiness feels good and
meaningful does meaningfulness doesn't
always in fact having this meaningful
life is often quite painful and hard
entrepreneurs have a very meaningful
life nurses doctors have a very
meaningful life but it's not always a
happy one
the second difference is that the
individuals and the happiness sort of
sell say that they really are self
focused they'll stay their sole focus
they'd like to give themselves gifts the
meaningfulness individuals aren't
they're really anchored on others
they're more likely to to sort of feel
joy when others feel joy and are much
more other oriented happiness feels
fleeting so they're much more focused on
how they feel right now meaningfulness
individuals are more focused on a
lasting sense of happiness where the
past and the present in the future are
blended so there are some studies that
have actually manipulated happiness and
meaningfulness in one study researchers
asked half the subjects do one thing
today that makes you happy and
the other condition they'll say do one
thing today to create meaning and then
they'll have individuals in both cells
come back to the lab and they'll track
them over time higher sense of meaning
of purpose correlates with higher levels
of good cholesterol healthier weight
better sleep lower levels of cortisol
cortisol is fine for short run bursts to
get away from bears but sustain levels
of cortisol aren't good lower risk of
cardiovascular disease and a lower risk
of cognitive decay so there's a sense of
meaning and purpose in our lives that's
very intuitive especially if you're a
religious person this is not rocket
science or if you have a family that you
feel very connected to again this is
very intuitive findings but it's
interesting how powerful they are and
it's also interesting that Gallup and
others show that individuals at work
when asked do you have a sense of
meaning or purpose at work or do you
even know what the mission of your work
is of your company 80% will say no I
don't and of the 20% who say I do when
asked do you personally resonate with
that mission they will say that large
majority seventy-five percent say no so
even if we have a sense of meaning and
purpose in our life the the very
significant chance that we don't at work
is is actually quite real and employees
who say they derive meaning at work are
three times more likely to stay one
point four times more engaged in one
point seven times report higher levels
of job satisfaction so the bottom line
effects of having a sense of meaning a
purpose at work translate to something
quite substantial so the question is how
do you find purpose something that is
deeply meaningful to you and I'm gonna
give you a sort of a couple of different
tips and also things to write down so
you have your piece of paper out right
everyone's Andy all right this is these
are some things that we do that's
informed by our research and then we
also do it with our students
so some people were born with a sense of
purpose others don't
nor necessarily even want to but the
reality is it's more of a skill than we
think
so first consider whether you have a
moonshot right now so the way we'll
define moonshot is is aligned with the
way X or Google X defines it at Google
they created moon shots there their
company called X and their purpose there
is to invent and launch moonshot
technologies that make the world a
radically better place now whether
there's a good business model for this
or not is another conversation but it's
interesting to learn actually I think
from companies the way they define it is
there is a huge problem they there's a
radical solution like 10 times better
than we could ever dream and a
breakthrough technology now a lot of
these ideas translate to what we know
from an individual perspective what we
could be doing that's much more
potentially ambitious than we we
potentially are currently pursuing you
know sort of classic works suggest that
if you are connected to your passion so
that provides the fuel your unique
strengths your highest and best use and
then what the world needs in the world
needs so much right now that's not too
hard then you'll be sort of in that Venn
diagram intersection more connected to
your purpose or what potentially could
be a moonshot so a personal story I was
one of these people that I don't know if
you've ever felt this but like so first
of all I don't really care about
marketing so just put that out there
it's unfortunate because I'm a marketing
professor but I also don't really care
about helping companies which is also
unfortunate because I'm in the business
school and so but I always wanted to be
an oncologist I wanted to make a dent in
cancer I think all of us have been
touched by cancer in one way or another
raise your hands if you directly or even
indirectly been touched by cancer and it
feels so real even for those of us who
have been lightly touched but I was
worried about being a doctor I didn't
know if
would be able to be a good mom and a
great partner and a great friend and and
I saw my parents be these incredible
incredible parents and I really want I
aspire to that and so I went and became
a behavioral psychologist and and went
into marketing which is what my dad was
in and I saw that my skill sets really
lined up with what he had and we were
both very efficient and highly
quantitative we were very driven we
didn't need a boss and we loved research
so what I eventually made my way and and
be kind of became a marketing professor
and but every Sunday I would feel kind
of empty so I don't know if you had
these Sundays where like you feel like
weirdly depressed and you're not sure
why and I would have those empty Sundays
especially Sunday afternoon and you know
fast-forward I got hired by UCLA for
four years still felt empty came back to
Stanford on Sundays got married and had
children and I felt less empty but I
still had this twinge of emptiness on
Sundays and I I think you know and I
used to give these big talks for PhD
students and whatnot and saying listen
let's all face it we're you know we're
in marketing we're trying to teach you
know privileged people how to make more
money at Stanford you know let's not
take ourselves too seriously we're not
curing cancer here and and it would be
kind of helpful for these PhD students
because they want to feel so heavy but I
think that had something to do with my
emptiness on Sundays fast forward and I
think all like a lot of people I talk to
have like closeted careers like if I
could quit now and like do something new
I know exactly what I would do but for
whatever reason we went this other path
right so fast forward I went to Berkeley
for a couple years and then before
coming back to Stanford and I was
teaching a creativity and innovation
class there and I asked my students you
know to share a story of what how they
change because of the class and one of
the students shared with me a story and
the story was so impactful and it was
about his best friend who had leukemia
and a process by which he harnessed
social networks and story
in order to get over 20,000 25,000
people in the bone marrow registry in
order to try and save the life of his
best friend because he needed a match
and he was South Asian so then the odds
of survival are incredibly small because
there's very few matches in the in the
in the registry for him and in that
process Robert my student found a
perfect match for Samir his best friend
along with Robert's friends and family
and this story that he shared with me
the end of my class was so impactful
that I went back that night and talked
to my husband Andy and and I said we
should write a book about that story
it's incredible it's about how do you
harness social technology and power of
story to actually make big change even
if you have no money nor resources no
anything and he did he quit his job but
we wrote a book together what's called
the Dragonfly effect and it was
absolutely meaningful it was absolutely
a moonshot for me and for Andy because
what was interesting about it is not
only were we able to write that book but
we were able to redefine success for
ourselves and our family we you know
instead of defining success by how much
money we made and maximizing money
because this is not a smart financial
move let me just tell you but we but are
a real measure of success was we wanted
our kids to be inspired to do massive
good in the world to be really impactful
we wanted them to be like Kennedy kids
but without the issues so we wanted them
to you know really just rise to that
occasion and that's really hard to
inspire when I'm at Stanford all the
time and ease that dole be all the time
and our kids are at home like they're
not seeing us and we're not gonna move
to Darfur cuz you know nails like I'm
not going to be able to do it so how do
we do good and how do we inspire them to
do good when we're not really living
that life in front of them and what the
book Dragonfly allowed us to do we spent
a year working with 12 students here to
try and get over a hundred thousand
people in the bone marrow registry in
order to give homage and to Robert and
also Samir and that was incredibly
gratifying
kids were very involved so what was
powerful about this is our metric of
success changed instead of saying we're
maximizing profitability or we're
maximizing what we should be doing we
think we should be doing instead we said
our metric of success was that our kids
would be connected to charities and
doing good and we would get more than a
hundred thousand people in the bone
marrow registry so every summer now our
kids create their own little businesses
find their own favorite charities and
then donate that money to those
charities instead of swim team or tennis
team they actually do that and that was
really exciting and inspiring for us now
your meaning or purpose doesn't have to
be something that launches you to the
moon it could be something as simple as
making a difference in just one person's
life it's better to light one small
candle than to curse the darkness all
right so take 30 seconds right now and
based on that little story just write
down a couple of glimmers of moonshots
or or goals and pour net goals that you
might take on in the next five or ten
years all right the second tool that we
talk a lot about is thinking back about
the most defining stories of your life
as John mentioned I teach also a class
called the power of story and what I
find is this simple exercise is
incredibly illuminating for a sense of
purpose so just write those stories down
they will inspire you and provide
clarity around your North Star so
Hemingway it was once known to have
written the first six word story he
wrote baby shoes for sale never worn and
so I make my students write six words
stories like not quite aspiring to be
quite tonight he packs tomorrow I pine
married the wrong girl fixed it
getting old ringtones pissed me off so
what I'd like you to do is write down in
30 seconds or less just one six word
story about your your life and if you
are good at this
keep writing more stories I usually give
everyone two minutes I'm only giving you
30 seconds so six words or less write
down some defining stories of your life
so the second thing I often do with my
students is after they've written down
all of their two minutes of six-word
stories I'll ask them to go through all
of the stories and pick out the
through-line or the common themes that
keep bubbling up in each of these
stories and if you look at those through
lines or those themes it's really
remarkable how much that eliminates a
key part of your purpose or northstar
alright next let's talk about the
journey the journey concept is also
unclear and esoteric what do you
actually need to pack for your journey
so the things to pack we will contend
our secret weapons you need a tribe and
you also need a way to defuse tension
because if you're gonna be playing at
the top of your game anchored on
moonshots you need a way to actually
defuse tension because it will be high
stakes it will be serious it will be
ambitious so how do you cultivate these
things and we will contend that humor is
the answer if you can balance gravity
with levity most things that humor is
fun and frivolous in reality it matters
a lot it has an outsized impact on our
ability to both make progress toward our
destination and also to embrace the
journey because it's a multiplier and
what would mean by that is it serves at
least three functions if not more humor
is a secret weapon here's a quote by
dick Estelle oh and that we liked it was
a tweet
in one of our studies are actually not
our studies this was by Brad bitterly
Allison Brooks and Maury Schweitzer what
they did was they studied the influence
of humor on status in new and existing
relationships and what they found is
when people use humor successfully which
I know is an art which is why we have an
entire class on it increased levels of
confidence and person competence are
perceived by people and that accrues
status or perceived status so you try a
joke you land that joke and I attribute
you more confidence confidence and also
status so humor plays also a fundamental
role in shaping relationships and it can
build your tribe in another study
researchers told people to write down
five pieces of personal information in
one condition
you guys saw a neutral film and then
wrote down that personal information in
the second condition you saw a humorous
film clip and then wrote down that
personal information and the results
suggested that in the humor condition
you self disclosed more to other
individuals in the experiment so you are
more open there's a lot of research to
show that oxytocin is released when
people laugh it opens people up and
Trust is able to be cultivated moments
of laughter sparked trust in a quickened
self disclosure it solidifies your
tribes closeness over time it can
significantly impact culture
it also diffuses tension in another
study researchers had two conditions and
they had a confederate say my final
offer is blank and then another
condition the Confederates said my final
offer is blank and I'll throw in my pet
frog and these researchers measured
concessions and how that negotiation
went and what they found was in the
second condition there was 18% more
concessions and not only that that
subjects reported increased enjoyment of
the task and reduced tension
Angela Merkel wrote humor is important
in politics I laugh at least once every
day otherwise I cannot do my job I would
never allow people to take away my
holiday for me and it's a really sad
state of affairs when we're quoting
German Chancellor Angela Merkel like we
were we're in bad shape people we gotta
like start learning from very
unsuspecting forces now humor is a super
power but there is this problem our self
perceptions of funniness plummet as we
age it turns out that we have data from
Gallup it's corroborated with
experimental data as well that we have
high perceptions of how funny we are
when we're kids
and we're also doing a pretty good job
when we're like you know adolescence and
then it basically plummets at around 21
23 ish when we enter the workforce and
you know it might be because we're very
important and efficient it might because
we landed it tried Atlanta joke and it
bombed it might be because it's a new
context and we don't know how to read
the room
or we don't have status but for whatever
reason our self perceptions of humor
globally plummet this isn't a u.s.
problem this is a worldwide problem and
because humor and laughing is associated
with health benefits performance
benefits creativity benefits this is a
significant problem so how do we move
the needle on humor first know your own
funny so there's so many different types
of humor right and this is I mean
culturally gender I mean it's it's a
humorous incredibly individualistic so
really kind of getting back in touch
with your sense of humor is important I
am voted the least funny person in my
five person family everyone is hilarious
but apparently not me they took a vote
and that's the verdict now and I would
agree with them I
didn't vote because they do secret
voting behind my back but if I did don't
worry I'm fine like their we're all very
supportive of each other but when I'm in
another country I'm hilarious I crush I
could do live stand-up and now here in
the United States when I'm at home there
is a lot to do and we don't have any
time to be funny we got to get the show
on the road but when I travel and then
I'm good so our family keeps traveling
we move a different country like every
year for at least two to four months and
even if I move to New York I'm funny so
I'll go to New York we went to Sydney we
just moved to Stockholm we're looking
for our next destination so and I'm
thinking Berlin honestly I'm gonna learn
from Germany right now so if anyone has
any connections just putting it out
there in the world our family is ready
to move and we will move in with you so
email me later if you if you if you have
a boat for where we should go next all
right so really quickly I'd like you to
write down think about the last time you
really loved bonus points if you were at
work or were the one creating humor what
was happening just wrote right down that
last moment and if you have extra time
and that becomes easy for you ask
yourself how might you cultivate more
moments like this next find your humor
tribe so for me what what happens
because humor is such a social emotion
it's very helpful both at work and in
life to have a set of people who get
you're funny or if you bomb they'll
still laugh and they won't judge you for
me it's my bridge group we don't play
bridge but I always wanted a bridge
group and I saw my mom had a bridge
group and I was insanely jealous like
all they would do is like drink and
whine and laugh and not play cards
so at fast forward like 40 years or
whatever and I finally have a bridge
group of these ten women who are
hilarious and we all drink wine and not
play cards and we
interesting about that is I am actually
pretty funny with them they have not
done a vote but I'm sure I'm among the
top in terms of humor what's also
important though because remember the
data about actually laughing less when
you enter the workforce is have one or
two people at work that is part of your
humor tribe so I mentioned to you Naomi
bagged onus teaches the humor class with
me as well as the rethinking purpose
class this year and and she is hilarious
she is like SNL funny and the tweets and
the videos and the pranks and the
stories that are cultivated with her are
game-changing and what was so
interesting is in order to scale that we
need to create a larger tribe because we
can't be funny all the time we got work
to do too and even though we're teaching
a class on humor and so we put out a set
of applications to be on our teaching
team and we were flooded with with
people responding and always said was we
want to create SNL meets I do and now
we've got this incredible 11 person
teaching team that was pulled from just
a huge number of applicants and now we
can really start to scale we move
quickly we work all of the time
literally this team works like 24/7 and
we're having so much fun doing it and
we're so productive and the quality of
the work is so much higher than before
so I'd like you to write down just two
or three names of individuals ideally
maybe one from your personal life and
potentially one from work that might be
your humor try these are people that you
might want to invite in if if you if you
ever wanted to like take on a humor boot
camp for example all right lastly
realize that humor is a choice it's a
filter through which we could view the
world our stories define us and we get
to choose the genre in one study with
Emily garb in scheme we asked
individuals to list the stories that
define their life so far similar to what
you did before and then we asked them to
rate whether they were dramas comedies
etc and well and then we took a whole
host of other measures like
self-perceptions on on creativity
performance success etc if the stories
were disproportionately self rated as
tragedies you might imagine participants
also it was a correlational study but it
was still a large effect size they
reported to be more anxious stress sad
disappointed feeling lonely or alone if
they also reported their stories to be
disproportionately dramas actually the
same effect happened but when they
self-reported their their stories to be
comedies they not only felt happier and
more satisfied but energetic fulfilled
inspired and challenged in life not only
that but they also said their life was
more meaningful so it wasn't just happy
but it was meaningful that upper white
hand quadrant of the of the categories I
discussed before so what I'd like you to
do is just take a second and look back
at the story that you wrote earlier and
see if it wasn't already a comedy could
you actually rewrite it as a comedy
alright
so Mel Brooks once said comedy abounds
if you just look around you and if you
do you will all have a new superpower so
in some no that happiness is miserable
or at least chasing it is real success
comes down to anchoring on the right
destination and embracing the journey
you need a compass to navigate the
destination and you need to know what to
pack for the journey
so capture the journey and stories but
also realize you get to pick the genre
Bill Murray once said if you can stay
light and stay loose and stay relaxed
you can play at the very highest level
as a baseball player or a human being
and this was shared when he actually
gave a speech to a bunch of baseball
players and he ended this speech with a
perfect bit of Zen stay at it but stay
light don't be afraid to do what comes
naturally fight the urge to be serious
don't let it destroy the very thing that
makes show
and and the guy who wrote this was
George Saunders and he he has a picture
of Bill Murray in his office just to
remind himself to stay out at the stay
lights so I encourage you to think about
who your humor hero is or what picture
you might put on the wall to remind you
how to balance the gravity with the
levity you're only given a little spark
of madness you mustn't lose it and the
question that I think is so interesting
is how will you keep the pilot light on
thank you
I'm gonna do one more thing and so
alright so Naomi and I are thinking like
what are we gonna do to sort of make
sure all of this content doesn't just
stay at Stanford but actually could be
sort of unlocked so to speak and so what
we're putting together right now this
week our teaching team is gonna beta
test it but what we're putting together
is like a one-week humor boot camp and
it's free and if you want to come where
you guys are a part of the party we'd
love you to to to participate and so
what we're trying to do is create a
little gift for you so to speak which is
a set of like maybe the most interesting
and fun humor covert spy missions that
you could actually take on so if you
want to participate in play with us and
I'm sort of an online experience where
we would just kind of email you and work
with you online
you are very invited to come all you
have to do is come to our website humor
serious business and sign up for the
boot camp and we'll probably have it
going in about a month and we encourage
you to to find a friend or two to do
this with because what we find is when
you do it with your family or like just
one other person at work it has
disproportionately better effects so
please join us if you'd like to you take
a picture of that and here's a bunch of
the books that also were infused in this
last part of the talk so if you're
interested in that dragonfly is the
least funny book that exists we put it
with all the funny stuff because you
know framing and then also elements of
style isn't necessarily funny but we
just love it so everything else very
useful and funny all right
that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]